In music, you're basically
having a conversation.
Here's a question.
Here's an answer.
Ooh, bit of a dodgy
question here.
I am convinced that I have
no idea how to do your movie.
It's always a blank
piece of paper.
I can tell you everything you
need to know in one word--
story.
All of it [INAUDIBLE],, set
designer, actor, writer,
composer-- we try
to create worlds.
Sherlock is a score
anybody could do.
One microphone on a laptop.
Ideas are not limited by budget.
The creative process
takes place in your head.
The interesting ideas
come from some kid
in a garage in the Bronx.
You just need to
break through the myth
that you can't create
a great Hollywood
blockbuster on an iPad because
if you [INAUDIBLE] story,
you can do whatever
you want to do.
I like your writing in D, and
it's nice that if you go from--
[MUSIC PLAYING] it's satisfying.
For "Batman," four French
horns on the right,
four French horns on the left,
and they're up in a gallery,
up way above the orchestra.
Two notes, but the
amount of expressiveness
you can put into them.
This is a musician's life.
Everybody tells you not to
do it and get a real job.
When all is said and done,
and we've filled the highest
highrises, and we built
the fastest machines,
there's still going to
be room for somebody
to tell you a story or somebody
to write you a piece of music.
The seconds of your
life are ticking away.
If somebody tells you that
there's a rule, break it.
That's the only thing
that move things forward.
I'm Hans Zimmer, and
this is my Masterclass.